okay hi I'm max actually the first sock
I'll ever hadn't given in front of an
audience that wasn't a bunch of
physicists so see how it goes and the
name of my talk today is working
interactively with large and remote data
in Jupiter lab so I'm sure most of you
are already familiar with the Jupiter
notebook so the Jupiter project as a
whole began life with you know just the
notebook and you actually would have to
you know change directory like a
terminal or something to the notebook
that you want to run and like run it on
it directly actually open anything but
over time more and more tools were added
to the ecosystem so you know big thing
was the you know rather nice file
browser that actually let you you know
navigate around and open multiple
notebooks and over time I playing
texador is also been added terminal and
so in making the next generation of
Jupiter notebook interface Jupiter lab
one of the goals of the developers has
been to create a more integrated
experience so if you're not familiar
with it this is sort of the view that
opens when you run Trooper lab for the
first time so there's a file browser on
the Left panel and then just the same
kind of notebook as notebook classic in
the main panel but you can also do many
many more things with Jupiter lab than
you could with notebook classic so you
can have multiple notebooks open running
in potentially different languages side
by side what's shown here on the sidebar
right there is a tool for editing the
metadata of the cells of each of the
notebooks then you can also have like
complex visualizations going on at the
same time next to that many many
different things and one of the new
things that you can do with Jupiter lab
that you couldn't do with notebook is
open many many different types of files
so that so for example you can open
image files you can open source files
Jason gives you like a nice little
preview you can open markdown files you
can also for many types of files open
more than one view of them so for
example for markdown files you can also
open a rendered view and of course you
can
new books and one of the really nifty
things that Jew blab can do miss for
example if you start a new console it's
kind of like a command-line interface
you can actually attach it to the same
kernel basically the same instance of
Python notebook that you just opened it
itself is running you can put them side
by side and so if you define you know
variables in the notebook say the
command line of the terminal becomes a
web sorry the console becomes aware of
them so those variables exist here and
you can actually modify them and they're
modified in the notebook as well
so one thing that I've heard a lot of
requests for is a way to you know for a
lot of users used Jupiter Jupiter lab to
interact with their data they want to
you know dig into it they want to
analyze it but one thing that's kind of
awkward to do right now is you know
given that you've navigated to some you
know data resource in the file browser
it's somewhat difficult or awkward to
then actually consume that resource in
your notebook you're basically stuck
just writing the same Python code you
know for importing that data source that
you would be anywhere so it'd be nice if
there was a way to more closely
integrate the file browser with a
notebook and just like that the content
stack of do plyo in general but there
are some problems with making that
happen and the biggest maybe fundamental
difficulty is just the architecture of
Jupiter itself and this is true for both
notebook classic and for lab is that
it's split into kind of three parts so
there is the browser which is the client
that's the thing that you actually like
see and interact with there's the server
which is the thing that's actually
grabbing the files off of your
filesystem and then there's the kernel
which is the Python instance or whatever
that's actually running in the notebook
itself and these are three separate
things that not only do they not need to
be running on the same computer they can
actually be running on different
continents and sort of a more immediate
problem is that part of the way that
Jupiter has avoided dealing with
these difficult problems is to make it
so that whenever you request a file in
your client the server will immediately
actually dump fetch the eagerly fetch
the entire contents of that file back to
your client so there's like a large
remote data transfer at that point
before your browser will actually like
render anything and so if your I
personally you know for my research I
often worked with files that were like
terabytes in size so for something like
that this is completely impractical
another limitation is that the file
browser itself is tied to just whatever
local file system the server happens to
be running on and so what we'd like is
for it to be more flexible for
essentially anything that is a data
store or anything that sort of looks
like a file system you know no matter
whether it's living locally or living
remotely that you'd be able to browse
through it using the file browser and
this is not a new problem so these
issues have been brought up since the
beginning of the duper lab project three
or four years ago but until now there
haven't really been any like practical
implementations of solutions for them
and so one solution for one small part
of the problem and it stupid lab hdf5
which allows you to open and interact
with potentially very large hdf5 files
with the in jupiter lab itself so if
you're not familiar with hdf5 files
they're basically like they're kind of
like a mini files mini file system in a
single file so it's they have like
direct groups which are just like
directories you know on your file system
and then they have datasets which are
just these like you know in simplest
terms like these tabular data sets of
numbers or whatever and give you demos
that
so the first thing that it lets you do
that you can do before it's actually
open the hdf5 file so this is not like
an actual file system this is the sort
of virtual file system inside the hdf5
file you can open these files and the
really nice thing is that this file that
I'm showing right here has a hundred
million entries and yet it opened it
loaded like really quickly
and you can you know let scroll through
you see you see that it populates itself
but it popular yes
what no there's absolutely no
restriction whatsoever yeah no I mean
that's the cool thing is it's basically
because it's lazily loading just the
data that it actually needs in order to
display it to you
it works with any literally any file
size as long as you know the back end
can touch it and may be a little weird
but a new feature that I'm really
excited about that I just added last
night is you can actually select the
data now and copy you know copy out of
that and paste it into whatever so for
example okay this data frame and so so
cut and paste is maybe not something
inherently to be that proud of but I
mean an implementation of it that
actually works you know remotely with
big data in the the duper lab I
architecture I think is actually a big
step forward for the project
so Jubilees h85 is great
and over time I'll be adding more more
new features to it but problem for the
larger project is that the ways that I
solved these problems the problems that
I described before for hdf5
are not really generally applicable so I
had to write a whole independent server
just for hdf5 files and then I actually
had to rewrite like a pretty significant
portion of the file browser UI in the
front end to make any of this work so
what we'd like instead would be some
kind of more unified way of consuming
many many different potential sources of
data you know remote data like a three
or just like alternative things like
czar in a unified way and you know there
are many many if we do it in if we do
this right there are many many cool
features we could add for example you
could copy data from is our file and
paste it into an hdf5 file you know
directly you know without needing to
actually have it on your local file
system editing any before you and the
really cool thing that we'd like to be
able to do is you know have an interface
by which all these things can be more
tightly coupled so essentially getting
back to that use case that I talked
about earlier of just navigating to some
resource in your file system no matter
where it lives being able to you know
say right-click on it and having you
know not necessarily anything we fancy
happened but essentially having it right
the boilerplate Python for you for
importing that resource that's that's
sort of like our vision for version 1 so
right-click on that dataset
and I select snippet and I get a say mmm
you know takes care of all the paths and
import statements everything for me and
you can do you know
Goodspeed that data set them to a
variable named data and then I can do
whatever I want with that um so just for
example um plot the first hundred rows
third column first hundred rows
that is your right there so it looks
like a you know I'm holy hairball but
that's because this is random data and
so along with sort of this more back-end
focused work there's also a bunch of new
experimental UI stuff that people are
doing so this is the work of one of my
colleagues at JP Morgan Tim Payne who is
working on a way to have multiple fire
browsers at once so most of these file
browsers are just tied to his local file
system but if you squint like right
there one of them is also tied to a
remote s3 store and yeah so it's right
now pretty easy even if you don't have
do blob install to start from scratch
and try for yourself those three
instructions assuming you have Python
installed yeah
in yeah I'm not gonna say yes because
I've never done it but yes you
definitely good any questions
in simple I mean it jupiter-like the
simple way to think about it is that
cheaper to labs and more is what he
asked
in simple terms what is Jupiter lab and
how is it different from notebook
classic so in simplest terms super lab
is a more integrative tool I hesitated
personally to call it integrated develop
an environment but some of my colleagues
do you can think of it like an IDE for
notebooks you like but essentially it's
to take all these different pieces that
we were working on sort of they were
sort of separated in Jupiter lab and
four started in Jupiter and tie them all
together in interesting new ways to
create interesting young useful new
interactions like you know some of the
stuff that I just showed you and the
other part of it is that the code base
of Jupiter of notebook classic isn't not
wholly mess and was hard to extend and I
think everyone was collectively agreed
that it was time to move on so the back
end can fetch the metadata right now but
there's no UI for it but there will be
in the near future we've matured maybe
have a conversation
I mean absolutely like that it would be
one of the things we'd want to be able
to handle how I'd like to elaborate on
the previous question about difference
between Jupiter Mars and Jupiter
notebooks is it only the difference in
the UI or the result of some difference
in the way the resources I manage the
performance manifest so one of the one
of the main goals of the project for
like the first release which was in July
was to get it to a point where the
experience of using the notebook in
Jupiter lab was at you know more or less
absolute parity with Jupiter class with
no Poe classic so the there's no real
difference that anybody should be
concerned with at least in terms of the
notebook itself if there is a difference
it's a bug and you should put on our
tracker no you can there's a so there's
doesn't look very good scrum shop but
there's this breadcrumbs thing on the
top so clicking on that will take you
back your home directory you know where
you started from and then you know if
you're like only a couple levels deep
you can just go back to like whatever
wherever you were before
if let's give it a hand your max
[Applause]